[Musique]
au fait si vous avez participé à la
saison 5 de dalles ceci vous dansez avec
christophe licata decani qatar a dit
qu'à des cathares on a fait une petite
compil de vos prestations
pour moi il est parti trop tôt ouais
mais franchement c'était une tannée
c'est vrai à la danse avec les stars il
est à dire expérience de 20 ans ont
ramené un cauchemar mais génial ouais
ils sont tous donc de ce que c'est des
mythos à la raison a dit samedi matin
tailleur en cuir jantes mais la caméra
dans la tronche si tu fais c'est pas
possible quoi seriez vous suivre toute
la journée
5 heures du matin ne savent pas c'est à
dire des jardins ont commencé ça veut
dire on va au pays c'est une telle
horreur c'est vous qui avez voulu partir
qui avait poussé pour partie - jamais le
cou cassé deux côtes cassées
ah ouais d'accord au près mais j'ai fait
une prime avec des portés comme ça avec
les côtes cassées j'ai demandé un
doliprane et je crois que c'était un peu
à côté de la plaque j'allais vrai je
pouvais plus respirer quoi awek le
troisième prime je devais sortie si fait
que j'étais arrêté au deuxième prime et
j'ai pas dis à la production que j'étais
arrêté par la vie par la veille ces
combattants avaient fait quand même
what's eating a redécouvert à présent ni
ses trois voulaient qu'on voit les
images on s'en fou comme on veut sans
fil
allez on serait allé vers si tu viens
ici tu penses tu veux
envie de revoir un autre truc d'ophélie
vous étiez venu me voir je faisais le
morning live en 2003 ouais je me levais
tôt et je me couchais tôt ouais c'est
agace et on a récupéré les images je me
rappelais plus tout ça vous étiez venus
voir et c'est vrai que l'on sait mais on
était copains regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est andy tu cherches un
excellent en est fou ton corps l'a fait
oui exactement
mais que ces défis
ophélie winter vous ici oui mais pas les
montres
vous avez
on n'a pas se mentir
au niveau du style on était sur le
professeur tournesol mais t'es sur qui
font un moment on était sûrs du
tournesol vous vous êtes resté très
belles mallettes en 22 matches là ça
revient très fort allez y ça revient
très fort